all right
we are now live for another political
theory
and practice discussion since i was
a shooting video my students about
thomas hobbes and since i think that
hobbed is a very important political
thinker i thought that i would do
a little talk presentation whatever you
want to call it about what what i think
is
interesting and also
um problematic dangerous a warning for
us
coming from thomas hobbes and then we'd
open it up for
some discussion i'm gonna start by
saying that i am not
a hobbesian anymore than i am a you know
pick
most other en's or ists or things like
that
um i have written you know quite a bit
on
hobbs earlier in my career in part
because i
i think his work is interesting and
worth
exploring and teaching but also because
i see
a kind of problematic that he
lays out for us that um
we can fall into and so it's not an
endorsement
on my part of his thinking but rather
you could say worries on my part
about the the dynamics that he's set out
and how easily we could shift into
a logic that is that is largely
described
by thomas hobbes not necessarily
entirely dictated by
so i should start at the start let's
let's talk about some of his his really
basic ideas
um you find these contained in
the the you know the mid part of the
portion of leviathan that we typically
read
um very few people read books three and
four because it's mostly just hobbs
rather unique theology and i wouldn't
i wouldn't suggest wasting your time on
it but when we come to books
one and two you know the first part is
really
him laying out his essentially
mechanistic
and materialistic views on human nature
and the mind and all that we get to the
real meat
when we get to talking about the
hobbesian state of nature
and hobbes is very famous you know most
people know
nasty brutish and short right they don't
they don't know the rest of that
quotation
which is that life is not just nasty
brutish and short but also
solitary right and why would it be
solitary
uh when you're living among other human
beings
because you can't rely on them
although you can indeed predict them but
you can't rely on them
to keep the peace and not engage in
conflict with you
and this is a significant problematic so
there's the hobbesian state of nature
which we'll come back to which is
as he calls it a state of war of all
against all
and you know it's debatable about
whether
he thinks that there really is such a
state of nature
we'll talk about that in in a moment um
it's definitely a danger that he views
on his part
then there are what he calls the laws of
nature and the laws of nature
there's he devotes two different
chapters to these
they're essentially moral norms but
they're moral norms
that require some sort of backing in
order to be
binding upon human beings
and that backing comes from this figure
who we call
the sovereign the authority and and
hobbes does say well you know you could
have different kinds of sovereigns
it you know power could be diffused in
some ways you could have a democracy
but he doesn't really think that that's
going to be effective
you know it's going to lead to the
problematic of
what we can call factionalization or
social breakdown
and we'll come to that in a bit that's
his biggest fear
so the the authority figure that he
thinks
that we need to
um put in place
has you know pretty extensive powers he
actually has
a chapter devoted just to what he calls
the rights
of the sovereign and we're going to see
that these are quite extensive
and lead to some some aspects that we
might find very
troubling particularly the one where the
sovereign gets to decide
what doctrines are fit to be taught as
truths within the commonwealth so that
that's a significant
issue um so
you know we put those those three parts
together
state of nature as this threat this
thing that we could degenerate into
laws of uh you know natural laws laws of
reasons that are binding upon
us in order to keep the peace and then
this authority figure who possesses you
know
lots and lots of power and um
who's going to be you know delegating
powers as well
and we've got a pretty decent picture of
the hobbesian
commonwealth the hobbesian solution to
things
what i want to suggest is that
regardless of what people claim to
believe
there is a tendency to
have things break down within societies
where
there's incredible ideological strife
and people making legitimate beefs
with each other and then a whole bunch
of illegitimate beefs and then all these
other
things like vanity can can play a role
or you know sort of strategic thinking
can play a role
there's a great danger of falling into a
hobbesian situation where it really does
look like
we have a state of war a state you know
a natural state that that's a
significant problem
and then there's a call for the
sovereign to be
you know erected or step in or do
something like that
and take over and remember too that
hobbs and sovereigns don't all have to
result from a social contract
they can be sovereigns by acquisition
where some
outside power comes in and takes over
right
that's also a possibility or you could
have just
one faction manages to win out within a
civil war like what happened
in in england that drove hobbs out of
england into france so
we do see this this sort of logic um
happening and
why did i bring this up in terms of
political theory and application
i think that we're here in america
um you know we're in a degenerating
political situation i would say
um there are there are a lot of people
within our society who are much less
invested in the society
remaining and and and perduring
and have these fantasies of like you
know
being on their own and they're taking
over
things like that and the problem is once
you've got enough people like that
within a society from a hobbesian
perspective
there's unless you clamp down on them
really hard
there's really not much you can do and
the rest of us wind up being kind of
screwed in the process
and being sucked into that logic
so let's talk about the state of nature
then
right and um
let me actually ask one of the people
who's put a question here
for some clarification uh procar has a
question that doesn't make sense to me
how does the hobby and state of nature
affect the process of constituting
i don't know what the process of
constituting is supposed to mean there
um so you know you'd have to you'd have
to clarify that
let's talk about the hobbs in the state
of nature though so
there are there are three main sources
for conflict hob says within this
state of nature which is kind of an
abstract model that he's setting out
one of them is what he calls competition
oh okay progress is constitution-making
process it doesn't affect the
constitution-making process
so they're they're not connected
um so the within the hobbs instead of
nature
one of the main sources of as hob says
quarrel
right or conflict is what he calls
competition
you've got stuff that i want i've got
stuff that you want
um i will come and try to take it from
you you'll come and try to take it from
me
so hob says anybody who actually you
know
invests their time and energy and mind
into something is always at risk of
having somebody else come along and take
it away from it could be one guy
it could be several people lined up you
know temporarily to rob that person to
spoil
them and he says listen it can be you
know your property it can be your
freedom you could be enslaved it could
be your life
within this this state of nature and not
only is nothing really safe
it's not safe because other people's
desires will motivate them to come and
take your stuff
and to use deadly force or you know
fraud or fear
whatever you're gonna have in order to
take it and you're probably gonna do
that too
because as a rational agent
unconstrained by any sort of moral norms
you'd like to think that you're a good
guy but you're actually just as bad of a
guy as everybody else you know
so you've got that that's the first
cause right that's already going to
bring people into conflict
here's where it gets more deadly if i
know
that you are likely to attack me
then i should probably this is the
rational thing to do
attack you before you can attack me not
even to take your stuff
just to defend myself against yourself
hobbes calls this anticipation
and he also calls this diffidence right
that's that's a kind of
funny word that we don't use anymore and
he says that you know because of this we
try to over
master other people we try to we try to
control them we try to
manage them we try to make sure that
they're not going to constitute a threat
to us
and at the same time they're motivated
by that same logic
so if i'm thinking that guy over there
is going to attack me i better attack
him first he's also thinking that
about me and he's and it can you know
iterate where it's like
you know i know that he's thinking he'd
better attack me first so i'd really
better attack him first right so we've
already got
now a much more volatile process where
now it's no longer just competition now
it's thinking
in terms of strategy then there's one
other thing
that introduces an additional wrinkle
and makes conflict almost
totally inevitable which is what hobbes
calls vanity
all of us want to be valued and we don't
want to be valued at the rate that other
people
assign to us we want to be valued at the
rate that
we feel that we deserve whether we're
reasonable about this or not so
you know i'm a amateur musician
you know i play a couple different
instruments and i can sing halfway
decently
imagine i go to my my friend scott
tarrouli who's a guitar professor
at berkeley school of music and who's
been a band leader
and you know has albums and he's played
with you know
really important acts as a studio
musician and a gigging musician
and i'm like hey scott i want to play
with you and he's like okay greg that
sounds good
and and i'm like okay um
we're going to play the songs that i
want to play because they're the ones
that i actually know on the bass
and i start playing and he's like you
know and he's a very
you know uh nice guy so he'd be like you
know i think that you're
kind of missing the beat and um you're
not doing that well maybe maybe we
should put this off
i could view that as a sign of dis
valuing he's not treating me
the way that i want to be treated right
and it doesn't matter
what he the expert thinks it's me this
schmuck who
you know shouldn't actually think highly
of himself wants to be thought more
highly of and we can we can extend this
to everything right think about
fields in which everybody they're not
everybody but
basically uh obstinate ignorant people
think that they're experts
you know a great example of this is
there's this astro
astrophysicist katie mack who constantly
gets
guys because it's always guys uh in this
case
who want to you know tell her
about astrophysics and then quote
wikipedia articles at her
they don't deserve to be viewed in the
same respect as she is right
um she's she's the the expert she
actually does work in the field these
guys are just a bunch of slobs who
you know have looked at a few videos or
something
like that and want to be placed on the
same
level we can see this in all sorts of
manners of life
right so when people don't get treated
the way that they demand to be treated
this is vanity then they are prone to
conflict
as well so now we've got three different
causes all
put together in this creative nature
how does this this is why you know it
leads to a state of war
and lives that are solitary
and so according to hobbes we need the
sovereign and that's why we need the
social protect and that's why
we need to follow these laws of nature
that we can figure out and we need the
sovereign to
impose these laws of nature so
where this gets dangerous is you know
when we ask ourselves
where is the state of nature and so
hobbes says
rather implausibly oh you know the
native americans they're like this you
know
it's not like that in other places
because they've developed you know
uh commonwealths and and we know from
history that this is just you know
uh bad ethnography but so hob says that
that's the may be the case
but where he's really interested in is
existing commonwealths like the english
one
or the french one which are in the
process
of breaking down because of
factionalization
as an aside too i would recommend if
you're really into hobbs
and you like this stuff in leviathan you
should read its companion piece which is
called behemoth
so leviathan and behemoth are two
biblical
creatures they're not even characters
they're just creatures and they
represent these giant things
they're talked about in the book of job
and the behemoth is an
by hobbs of the english civil war where
he traces out what happened here and
what happened here and how this led to
this and
how the society broke down along
factional lines we see similar things
happening you know think about when we
had
the invasion of iraq the second time
around and we deposed uh saddam hussein
and the united states did not have any
sort of
effective uh put things back together
plan
in place you know the original mission
of taking out
hussein and the both regime which was a
terrible totalitarian regime
and nobody should be in the dark about
that
but they didn't replace it with anything
else and they left
a society in which factions were going
to clash with each other and then they
then they tried to police it and that
was you know
more or less unsuccessful um
so hobbes thinks that there's a lot of
cases where you have
social breakdown within a previously
more or less functioning society never
functioning perfectly right
but at least able to like keep its its
stuff together and
make things work hobbes thinks that
that's the the really great danger
and the one of the reasons why he gives
the power to regulate
what gets taught what gets talked about
to the sovereign
is he realizes that people will use
for example teaching moral philosophy or
you know writing opinion pieces
in media or whatever it's going to be
they will use that to essentially carry
out
something like a covert war before a
real war breaks out
um he also talks about nations so like
international relations
basically being in a state of nature
that's true as well
and he also tells us that crime and our
attitudes towards crime
display our distrust of our fellow
citizens within a commonwealth you know
he says
you don't go around you know on the
highway without being
armed um you also
lock your doors and lock your chests and
stuff like that so there
there's there's something there and i
again i want to say
that my main point here is not to say
that hobbs
has everything totally right especially
not in his
you know saying well we what we need is
a powerful
authority who's got all these powers to
control and coerce us and that'll keep
us peaceful
i mean he does actually think some
social engineering is necessary another
one of the
rights of the sovereign is to give out
honors
and to assign dishonors to those who
you know exemplify or violate the laws
of nature and and you should read
through those laws of nature they are
more for hobbs moral laws that
correspond to the virtues right
and a lot of them have to do with like
not being a jerk to other people and
getting along
um and and dealing with conflicts in
such a way that
they can be appropriately put to bed
sooner or later um so
hobbes you know is outlining for us what
i think is
one of the great dangers of our own time
i don't want us to get into a hot sand
situation
and then we have to think about okay
what are the alternatives how do we get
beyond
this hobbesian logic all right so let's
let's look at some of the
uh questions um
no more backer wars says has
factionalism always been part of
american politics to some degree
to me early thought you know for example
franklin's virtue ethics in america
concerned working well with others
um yeah factionalism has been
uh an issue faction social social
breakdown into rival groups that are
trying to control things
and impose their view of things upon
the entire uh totality yeah i mean it
led to a civil war
that was decades in in coming
and then was one of the greatest um uh
bloodlettings in in american history
right
um so it's it's been an issue there
there have been other things you know
bringing the original colonies together
after the revolt there were there were
proposals to have like four different
essentially big states that would or
you know confederacies that would
represent the
the different uh areas better instead
they formed one
giant government through a number of
different compromises that that paved
over
um some of these ideological and
moral splits and eventually that led to
all sorts of
issues i i would say that another good
example of this is
you know the new deal was in significant
respect
a way to deal with the massive
inequalities and inefficiencies
of the american system of the time which
were
not just a matter of like people being
greedy or something they were idiot
ideological
um justifications for these things and
the nation
swung in a different way i would say
that we're
in a time of considerable
factionalization
right now you know a great example of
this
is the fact that even when the democrats
try to because the democrats are at this
point in time being much more reasonable
than the republicans
not perfectly so but quite a bit so even
when they try to do things in the
traditional political way which
you make compromises you can't get any
votes
right that's a that's a terrible sign
that that's that's a sign that we're in
real trouble
and unfortunately we have a two-party
system instead of like a multi-party
system so if one goes
bad uh we're kind of screwed you know i
unless they come back from the brink
somehow
i think that um you know we're going to
be in some some serious
problems now franklin's virtue ethics
right
um yeah i mean there he's he's
an example of this there were a lot of
people who
valued being able to come to terms with
others who you don't fundamentally agree
with
but you see some value in preserving the
political and social system you know
this is sort of like traditional
americanism right
you vote an election is done you suck it
up you wait until the next election
before
uh raising hell or something like that
right that's that's traditionally the
way things have been done the last time
that that
really didn't happen like that would you
know civil war right
um so you know those those are those are
some norms that were there i would say
that when it comes to
legislative issues the the norms
governing
bipartisanship and compromise and
reaching across the aisle have been
eroded
since the 1990s in significant ways
and both sides have contributed to that
you know very significantly there were a
lot of
dumb decisions which were great tactical
decisions but terrible strategic
decisions where
people said well we're going to do this
because we
have the power to do it right now and
then i would say well what's going to
happen when the republicans take control
and they do that or what's going to
happen with the democrats take back
control
and they do that and and nobody seems to
to really care
um so that's you know i would say that
we
we're having a lot of trouble with you
know and hobbs talks about a social
contract right so
this is actually a useful term to to
bring in in a broader
sense and there's two things i want to
say about that one is that
we did in fact have something more like
a viable social contract for at least
some of the population
in terms of our political ideology and
struggle and there have been some some
you know
problematic times where things swung too
far one way or the other
um there are a lot of people who are
left out of that social contract as well
and you know we can think in terms of
race we can also think in terms of
gender
we can think in terms of class um we can
think in terms of other
uh things that that disadvantage people
within the americas i think try you know
mills is right to say that
um for example african americans have
been left out of the social contract
by and large right especially when it
comes to
how it's applied you know when we get
down to the nuts and bolts of it and so
that means that if we're going to have a
social contract we need to have a better
one
if we want to hold a society together or
we can say that
it's all just politics and voting blocks
and then you know
really uh everybody will complain about
the other guy
but nobody really has a legitimate right
to complain about the other guy
right so all right so a lot more
questions
here let's see uh mf says those people
think that you're condescending to them
talking about the vanity thing right
yeah i mean that hobbs house is a very
good psychologist
in many respects when it comes to why
people fight with each other
he's not a great psychologist when it
comes to other things i'd say
dammit albert is bringing up the idea of
culture war and i would say yeah the
culture war
thing fits in with that and you know
this notion of being a culture
warrior or being in a culture war that
itself i think has been
a bad move that has produced much more
harm than than good because there's so
many people who
adopt that that vision of a war and they
do damage not just to their opponents
but also to themselves
if you have to lie to yourself about you
know what the
uh agenda of your opponents is um
you know like take the dr seuss [ __ ]
thing that's going on right i mean
anybody who legitimately thinks that
this is
cancel culture is nuts
nuts or you know simple-minded
and how do people get to the point where
this could actually have
legs and traction culture war right
um that's that's a real problem because
it's going to lead to more and more
you know once you start buying into a
few nutty ideas you're going to buy into
more and more of them it becomes like a
habit you shift from one to the next
just like somebody
who jumps from one uh crazy
new agey thing to another you know
um so this is going to be a significant
problem
um i don't know how we actually come
back from it other than
locally and i'm not all that um
i'm not all that optimistic about where
america goes from here um quite frankly
american exceptionalism is is a silly
fantasy that a lot of people have uh
and it keeps people from saying holy
[ __ ] we're in some real
trouble here we better fix this you know
we better be willing to make some
sacrifices and work with
other people so that things don't
completely fall apart
all right um mf asked do you think biden
should crack down on these crazy
far-right groups and mass burners
canada officially declared the proud
boys a terrorist group i think that um
i think that we should have been
cracking down on them from the 1990s
onward
um we for far too long we've allowed
white supremacist
uh groups which are almost always on the
right
to um get away with crap
you know i mean here in the wisconsin we
had the posse comitatus when i was a kid
and you know every once in a while the
fbi and the atf would come in and take
away their guns and
put some of them in prison and then
they'd crop back up again michigan's got
all these crazy militia people
i think they have they've effectively by
the way that they've behaved this is
where i actually am hobbesian
they have declared war on all of us all
of us who don't share their views
by walking or i think if you go to a
protest and you're armed
now it's unfortunate we can't rely on
the cops to actually do anything about
it because a lot of them are infiltrated
by it
um people who will go to protests armed
i don't care about second amendment
[ __ ] stuff
they're not part of a militia they're
terrorists
they're trying to induce terror in
others they're trying to coerce
and i would say yeah round them up you
know i would have
i would have zero problem with that at
that point and i think that should have
been done
long ago i think that when this sort of
sort of
stuff you know festers investors
investors and you do impotent gestures
towards them
um you allow it to to continue or
you know if if if we're going to let
everybody have all these guns and stuff
like that
then um let the uh let the leftists have
just as many
you know or let black lives matters come
to things totally armed to the teeth
people aren't for that right um they're
like well it's okay if this guy over
here from the suburbs who's got you know
20 guns in his safe
it's okay if he does it but it's not
okay if this guy over here has a
has a pistol you know it's got to go
both ways
um by the way i'm for cracking down on
any sort of left terrorist groups as
well
that are demonstrably so right
um tobias says world structure is still
anarchic we need a strong world
government to manage the pandemic and
the environment
otherwise we're doomed i mean we might
be doomed even with a strong world
government
that that that's something you should
think about
um and yeah as far as managing the
pandemic
the pandemic is a really interesting
issue so is the environment and
environmental degradation
which is going to force some massive
shifts of population
in the coming decades i mean all the
smart money
is on global warming is taking place all
the insurance companies
you know the military uh the rand
corporation they all know it's it's not
a hoax right
uh as a matter of fact until recently it
was only american conservatives who
believed it was a hoax and then
you know then conservatives and other
countries would
you know eventually sort of gravitate to
that but for
quite a long time um there there wasn't
any sort of
no no it's not happening or it's not
man-made or anything like that going on
so yeah i mean is world government where
we have to go in order to deal with that
um i don't think we're going to see a
world government getting
i mean think about the difficulties
of getting just the u.n security council
just those five countries
to the you know the permanent members
to get all on the same page about
anything
um russia china france britain us
that's tough i don't see any sort of
world government
coming about um so maybe we need you
know better multi-uh
lateral agreements um
maybe we do need a beefed up un that can
actually do things
um i don't know those those are those
are good questions i don't i don't know
that we want a hobby and sovereign
to handle these things right
all right dammit albert says people
today seem to deal with caricatures and
straw men versions of other people's
opinions
is this the result of social media
bubbles or factionalization as tech led
to us being less rational so that's a
great question
i would say that it's not quite the
causality is not quite so
simple as well tech came in and then
because there were
of course you know tendencies towards
that a lot of times in the past you know
just think about if you've ever read
anything by like the john birch society
and their particular brand of nuttiness
and they could be quite influential in
conservative circles you know in the
uh 60s 70s 80s even even into the 90s
um and you think about some of the other
things coming
as well um it's not like conspiracy
theories
worn around before that but yeah the
technology
social media and i would i would include
not just
social media but also like this vast
plethora of
news slash opinion sites that are out
there as well right people
read journals or newspapers or
other media producers and that's part of
what gets shared on social media
so think about the epic times for
example right
it largely exists online and people
constantly share that that stuff back
and forth
and it may it may have originally had a
decent um
start in calling attention to
persecution of falun gong by
the the chinese state but it's certainly
morphed into something that's
you know i would say pretty pretty um
noxious um
yeah so we we do in fact have the
possibility of like living a lifestyle
where
our online presence
our online life our connections are very
much in
silos or echo chambers um
it's you know i remember when i first
got on facebook
and i was struck by the fact you know i
was teaching critical thinking classes
at the time
and i would point out where both sides
because i i you know i've never been
uh ideologically committed to either the
right or the left in any
significant way i've always been very
pragmatic about those those sorts of
things
so i've been a critic of both in my
career
and i was being kind of an equal
opportunity
pointer outer and everybody hated you
that because
you're not in their their thing right so
i i would i don't is is it worse now
than it was
30 years ago um
i mean in certain respects yes it
depends on
who we're talking about so
yeah i'll just leave it at that i have
to give it a qualified yes
um verner says that i ever get into any
transhumanist philosophy
i mean in some respects nietzsche is
kind of a transhumanist you know
yearning for the ubermensch right and
thinking about what technologies of the
self we're gonna use to get there
but uh as far as like being a member of
that
movement no i'm i'm not really uh
allowing those those sort of lines i'm
not i'm not particularly optimistic
about the capacity for
ai to you know make our lives so much
better or for consciousness to get
uploaded
into um into computers or whatever other
form it's gonna be
um i mean we're all kind of
transhumanist in a way
or like you know um who's the author of
the cyborg manifesto pointed out we're
all kind of cyborgs to some degree
uh given all the things that we've we've
used right
but no i can't say i'm
i'm really that zeno says whenever
somebody mentions
banning books i think of fahrenheit 451
in 1984 well you probably shouldn't
because those
those are sort of like limit cases and
you should probably think more about
historical cases that are much closer to
hand rather than
um you know fiction being your go-to
um i mean if you want to think about
banning books there's there's websites
out there
for from the national library
association that tells you what books
are banned in what places
it's rarely being banned people from the
left banning books
in the united states it's usually
conservatives
and and sort of you know not not like
movement conservatives but
just kind of you know people who are
prudish and stuff like that saying oh
you can't read judy bloom or
or things like that
that's where our history has been for
the most part
all right uh werner did you read any
nick land i've never i've never actually
read nick land
i've long said if anybody wants to send
me
a physical copy not a pdf but a physical
copy of fang numina i'll read it
but i don't review books that i you know
unless i'm interested in
acquiring them i don't review books that
um
you know i'm not sent because my time is
so so short
all right uh
well here's a really good question from
ethan do you think there's any
connections between big tech's growing
power and hobbs absolute sovereign
so that that is a really great question
um i would say at this point in time no
and the reason is because big tech
names a number of competing companies
each of whom has um
pretensions let's say and and uh
acts upon those to totalize
to become to become something like a
hobby and sovereign
and a hobby and sovereign who would be
good for us right who would regulate
our lives who would offer us all the
stuff that we need so you know when
we're talking about big tech who are we
talking about
you know i would say we've got the big
five you know
top five market cap companies facebook
google amazon microsoft
um an apple right and then we've got
others
you know like tesla is kind of you know
connected but it's it's really more
tangential they're more about nuts and
bolts
yahoo had the possibility of making it
like that but their leadership
sucked so bad and they made so many
stupid decisions that they never managed
to do it
and each of them has things that they do
really well and then they want to get
into every other sector of our lives and
do those things as well so they all have
to have a virtual assistant right
it could be siri it could be cortada it
could be uh pic
you know alexa they all want to get into
streaming things they all want to get
into
distributing news they all want to do
all these different things
and so they're all in a certain way
totalizing
would they be totalitarian i mean you'd
have to say
to use that old phrase totalitarianism
with a human face right
but it's still pretty totalitarian
they're visions of what things are gonna
be like
and they're jockeying against each other
so
they they don't actually it's not like
there's just one out there
and it's not like there's one thing
called big tech like all of the
all of them sit down at a conference
table in some smoky room
and then you know uh say oh we're gonna
do this and this and this they're at
this point in time competing against
each other
could they become something like one big
vast conglomerate you know like we see
in
in some uh sci-fi and particularly
cyberpunk stuff
yeah maybe um but i i i i don't
really see that coming anytime
soon um it is pretty amazing
how they have managed to effectively
permeate and penetrate our contemporary
life i mean the fact that i'm talking to
you
on this this laptop you know macbook pro
up in my room surrounded by all these
books
um and i'm communicating with people on
who knows how many continents and we're
having a conversation about that
and we take that as normal you know
that is really quite something isn't it
and and the the idea that we would be
doing this
20 20 years ago so 2001
was you know something that's kind of on
the horizon very sci-fi
uh like um
just and then to go back like another uh
20 years to say 1981
when i was like
taking uh one of my first computer
classes
uh with my dad um things have really
changed a lot um at least in respect to
how tech permeates our lives
all right um ethan says
i have a religious studies professor who
connects the modern surveillance state
with nicholas takuza's
concept of look i don't know nicholas
dakuza's concept of the looks so
i wouldn't be able to say anything there
werner how likely do you think an event
such as the singularity as described by
ray kurzweil is likely to happen this
century
i mean i don't i don't think the
singularity is is really
going to happen um maybe something
halfway like it uh but i don't i don't
see
all of this you know reaching this this
point where suddenly all of these things
transform
i mean my experience has been that there
are tipping points for
for things but i i don't um
they're almost impossible to predict so
the idea that ray kurzweil got it right
is you know pretty uh staggering for
for me um uh
kushis says falun gong is a dangerous
cult
maybe so um the chinese government i
think you could also say is a vast much
more dangerous cult
so all right uh let's see what else we
got
mf what does conservative even mean
nowadays all i see is cruelty vanity
nuttiness and don't be a [ __ ] attitude
from them
yeah i i mean i see more right than that
but i
i will say that conservative is one of
those slippery terms where
conservatives of 1980 would look at con
you know so-called conservatives of
today
and say you are garbage people you you
have no connection with us
whatsoever at least some of the
conservatives would some of the ones who
are like
hardcore racists or covert racists would
say you
you know you go with that um but yeah
conservative
it's interesting because there's a lot
of different ways of understanding what
it means to be conservative
conservative means that you actually do
have to conserve something
traditional conservatives were about
conserving the environment conservation
right uh conservatives today you know
some of them
would just love to destroy as much of it
as possible
and you're like what the hell is wrong
with you why are you taking these weird
positions
that are you know irrational and and
they've you know they've got
justifications for it but they're
irrational
justifications it's i used to say
you know about 10 years ago i'm too
traditional to be a conservative
because i saw where you know the
conservative movement was going and i
was like this isn't conservative at all
um i mean you get to 50 years old you
get to see a lot of stuff
right if you got your eyes open all
right
duke duke says yeah if you don't
perfectly align with a strict ideology
you are a true social pariah
yeah it'd be nice if you could be like
uh you know
able to like talk with people from a lot
of different things
um but but in fact often they view you
as
if you're not one of them you're one of
those others
so that that's a problem um all right
kapit says i would say so many
snowflakes getting mad over free speech
is where the problem is
um i don't even know what that that
means that could be taken in so many
different
ways i mean i see snowflakes all around
um all right edwin a lie can travel
halfway around the world before the
truth can get its boots on apocryphal
but entirely accurate in the age of
social media that is that is a
significant
disadvantage simple lies are
so easy to to transmit and and you're
right in the age of social media
so like in in the past right if
something was going to be reported
on tv you'd have to wait until like the
five o'clock news or there might be like
an important news
break you know in the middle of the day
breaking into the regular program
or you might hear it on the radio or it
might get into the newspaper in the
evening edition or something like that
now we're in this 24 hours news cycle
where people are constantly
hungry for stories and
we have the ability to to reproduce the
information
and transfer to somebody else so much
more quickly
um no more backer wars i've noticed
important thinkers are writers in the
past
hobbs edmund spencer plato had to be
obsequious to ruling figures to get
positions or their moral problems to
this can we do it now
that's a good question um yeah i mean
anybody who gets reported as being like
the so-and-soul philosopher
and they're associated with some
political figure i automatically think
they're they're probably full of [ __ ]
right especially if they're from some
ivy league institution um
because the ivy leaguers aren't any any
better or smarter than the rest of us
they're just better connected
i mean hobbs uh hobbs
so he was associated with the king i
don't know that he had to be obsequious
to the king
um plato um you're thinking about
uh dionysus um the tyrant that he was
he was connected with um
spencer i don't know who who is who is
he uh
having to kowtow to i don't know i mean
is it problematic to get to have a
patron
i don't think so it really depends on
what the patron demands from you and
what you
want i mean in hobbs case he published
leviathan and the king wasn't happy with
it the king
the king didn't want anything quite so
radical
as what hobbs was proposing right uh
dionysus we know plato got there and he
thought he was working with somebody who
could be like a philosopher king
and he turned out to be a tyrant and
then plato
you know then started figuring how the
hell am i going to get out of here
right so um
all right
cody asks is there any merit to the idea
that the right left distinction may
muddy the waters more than help
political discourse
i mean given that in america
the democratic party and the republican
party
definite i mean both of them will claim
to be like not true americans but they
also both
definitely lean one way or the other
um and i mean the the american
democratic party is not really
left compared to european leftist
parties or even you know
in other uh developed countries as well
but
it's left as far as america is concerned
i think it's useful but i think that
people
make way too much of it and it does it
does really get in the way of
any sort of compromise or bipartisanship
that would be motivated by a common good
you know
that's part of the problem is we don't
have very many politicians who are
motivated by anything like a genuine
common good
um and it's probably going to take
generations before we see anything like
that
if we do you know at the local level yes
but you get up into the national level
it's a lot harder right
um don says the movie 2001 with its
video calling
was made in 1968 the the vision has been
coming for a good while but it's
amazingly normal now to normal let me
check my phone
um yeah you know 2001 is kind of a funny
one
i didn't see it until i was like a high
schooler
and it had been talked up so much that i
i didn't like it you know i was like
i don't want to watch an eye change
colors for minutes after minutes you
know
what's what's this about you know um
i guess you know talking with my dad who
actually saw it in the theater
uh it was kind of mind-blowing at the
time but yeah
all right uh matt bennett we take that
as a normal crazy to think about in that
way i remember three channels on tv and
rotary phones yeah i mean
me too being 50 years old being
generation x
it means that you grew up if you grew up
here in america means that you grew up
in a time when you saw all these
important tech
transitions take place
which included moving away from if you
lived out in the country having three or
four channels we could get the public
broadcast uh station if the weather was
was right um to then having you know
a good antenna and then eventually cable
and then you know video game started out
with you know like crappy atari
right and then got better and better and
better home computers
um you know more
telecommunication devices and then going
through all of these
transitions you know dial-up modems the
the early web and stuff like that
it's really um quite amazing how
quick we adapt to this stuff and and for
me
i'm i'm also conservative in in not in
the political sense but like
not liking change you know i don't like
when i have to do updates for my
computer because i'm like leave it alone
unless it's broken you know
um i don't like to change from like when
i had to switch from
pc to apple did not like that at all
um didn't like going from cassettes to
cds
and and so you know i've been sort of
like dragged along
uh the way i think many of you have as
well into new technology after new
technology
my wife by the way is sort of the
opposite she's one of those
early adopters who's like oh this is
amazing let's try this out you know
and um people who jump into things
often know a lot more about them
all right um william evans is freedom
freedom free to be squashed i wouldn't
say that freedom is free to be squashed
it's more like is freedom vulnerable to
be squashed and the answer is always yes
i mean
the things that we take as freedoms very
easily all it takes is like a couple
things to go wrong
and a great example this right so what's
happening in britain right you know
right now
a woman gets abducted and then killed by
a police officer a metropolitan police
officer
they go through a couple days of the
case and then they're holding
a vigil for her
um and then the the met policemen
it's a visual about you know like
women's rights and
the danger posed by people where the the
aggressor was a police officer
and what do the cops do to come in and
use excessive force and grope women
at this thing and then of course it gets
video recorded and put out there
and you know you think about
what are the cops doing when they're not
being recorded
or you know what given that they do bad
stuff even while they're being recorded
and think that they've got complete
impunity
what are all these other people who have
um
that sort of uh power imbalance what do
they do
i mean a great example this is if you
think about
sexual abuse children right
one of the things that i discovered when
i was when i was researching this way
back when i was when i was
first starting teaching was the rates of
reporting of abuse are about the same in
every single profession where there's
unsupervised
interaction with children social workers
police
teachers clergy
medical professionals pick whoever you
want right there's something about
this this uh not being um
surveilled you know it's interesting too
so this reminds me uh
of another thing you know actually maybe
i'll do a thing on this down the line in
this political theory and application
dostoevsky's grand inquisitor chapter of
brothers karamazov right
the central problem in that chapter that
the grand inquisitor is talking about
is freedom um human freedom
includes the freedom to screw up other
people to interfere with their freedom
to harm them to victimize them
and you know what do we do well we have
to like have laws to stay in the way and
authority figures to
do that and then those those laws and
authority figures can be also corrupted
and
uh this is a very basic problematic and
so yeah freedom
is never you know if if we're in a point
where our
our freedom is like something we can
like be so confident in
we're lucky you know that's that's not
the case in
in many places and times and it doesn't
take that long to go back to the
hobbesian thing
for us to wind up in something like a st
you know state of nature maybe just for
this block or this
this point in time right
all right uh let's see here
i'll just skip a little bit um
[Music]
so don quix was politics as crazily
polarized ever in the past that i know
of
yeah it's i've often said
because people like to say oh you know
the united states sort of like the roman
empire that's what's falling i always
say
read william shire's decline and fall
of the french third republic because if
you read that book
and you look at what was happening uh in
the french political system of the time
it looks an awful lot like
ours you know we had right and left
unable to work with each other
massive inequalities of wealth a
gridlock political system
uh you know france had encircled germany
with all these alliances
and spent tons and tons of money on
military expenditures
which ended up being largely ineffective
because they didn't have the guts to
actually do what needed to be done when
they could have
crushed the nazi regime early on
there's lots of places and times where
fractionalization
leads to the rot from within
and it can sometimes take decades before
something pushes it over
so yeah i i think there's there's lots
of cases like that
uh noxious tax land was young dr sadler
a bit of a hipster i was never a hipster
um because for me a hipster is somebody
who's like
you know wearing the trucker wallet when
they're not a trucker
or not connected with anybody who's a
trucker you know the people who
brag about their you know esoteric
tastes and this and that
i always hated hipsters um and we had
plenty of them
in different places where where i lived
um they weren't brooklyn hipsters
obviously because i never lived in
brooklyn but we had our
our own homegrown versions of them in
all sorts of places
um but no i've never really been um
i've never really been a joiner you know
um
so i've always i've always uh studied
um if not philosophy at least ideas
and that's going to make you kind of
unpopular to begin with especially if
you want to apply them and experiment
with them
um so but i guess it depends on what you
what you think of as a hipster right
uh cody we judge the maturity of a
society
by how well it adheres to serving the
common good at this point much of the
west is still in its adolescent phase
um i mean it might have been an adult
that then got denial or something like
that
um and the common good
would really need to be something that
isn't just
an ideal but is something that can be
lived out by all the members of
of the society i'd say you know
fatal remains unlike political factions
in the past i see modern political
factions are in some way
much less defined by material interests
but rather abstract social identities
that can be redefined ad hoc
i mean why not both um i think that that
um
material interests certainly when we
talk i mean
this is something where we can we can
talk about both parties being rotten and
corrupt
uh in this case um certainly
the the elite the people who have tons
and tons of money and enjoy a lot of
social prestige and power and stuff like
that
um they're they're interested in
you know preserving their material
interests aren't they
and there's a lot of other people that
are that are motivated by it as well
um it's it's
i think you you are right that um
you know if we looked at other societies
and how they
treat more or less ordinary people
um and and we really took that to heart
um we would have things like a higher
minimum wage we would have universal
health care we would we would you know
have a lot of things
better housing policies and things like
that that would serve
ordinary people um
it's amazing that and you are right it's
amazing that
um here in america i mean this is
something that the brits
the tories managed to do in britain too
and other people have done in other
places like the
uh labor party in australia to convince
people to go
clearly against their own material
interests
uh in the name of you know freedom or
something like that or you know keeping
the government out of my stuff
um it's really quite a um
ideological bamboozle i guess i mean on
the part of the left it's often much
more in america that centrist uh
democrats get people who want you know
things that would be more equitable to
buy in and vote for them and then they
don't deliver
you know um so yeah
all right um
let's see dylan in past videos you've
talked about being an educator for
prisoners
what are your views on prison abolition
angela davis talks about this is it
truly
possible or more idealistic than
realistic
i mean i i think it is an idealistic
position
the idea that would just get rid of
prisons all together
certainly our so here's one of the
things that
i always say we don't have a prison
system here in the united states
instead we have you know federal prisons
we have each state has its own
department of corrections
sometimes not even called that it might
be called you know bureau of
corrections or whatever and each state
has its own entity
and then within it each prison is its
own
entity some may be run better than
others then we have each county has its
own jail system
some county jail systems like cook
county jail system down in chicago is
larger than some state docs
the la county jail system i think is the
biggest
in the world in terms of jail systems
and each one is its own kind of animal
and
there's there's so many things within
um this this vast set of interlocking
systems
that have been done badly and sometimes
they're done badly because the desire is
to like be
retributive towards prisoners and say
they don't deserve anything um
you know
there's there's also like a lot of weird
ideas that people have
like you know oh you know they they've
got it so easy in prison they're getting
three square meals a day and they get to
watch
tv and then when you look at the
realities of this the three square meals
like when i was teaching at indiana
state prison
um before aramark came in air mark is a
catering company
and they do a lot of prison uh um
food systems before they came in the
state was spending something like 77
cents
per day on each prisoner for three meals
so you can guess that it wasn't it
wasn't particularly nourishing
or healthy or in some cases even
plentiful
food and then prisoners can buy their
own food on what was called commissary
there is called canteen in other places
and they pay inflated prices for for
everything including
not just food but they can buy a tv if
they want to at way more than you would
ever pay for a tv
for for that sort of thing and guards
love prisoners to have tv
because it's one more thing they can
take away from them so they it can it
can ensure compliance
and so there's all of these you know
attitudes from people on the outside
like you know when i was teaching
in the prisons i my relatives would
often get pissed off at me
for doing so and these would be
relatives from illinois
and we'd be together at like family
stuff and they'd be like i can't believe
that my kids have to pay for college
i have to pay for my kids college and
these prisoners get to go to college for
free and i'd be like
you're not even in my state why do you
give a [ __ ] you know and then second
they're getting the same low income
grant that any other person in indiana
would until of course they
they cut the grant right um but
all this sort of busy bodiness there's
very few people
in i would say in america except for
those who who have people who are
incarcerated or who got involved in it
in some way
who see what the prisons are like and
and
everything we're seeing is just a little
window it's not like the whole system
um could you abolish something like that
that's not a
system but a whole bunch of interlocking
systems i don't think so
what can you do you can work for reform
you can try to make things better you
can
try to hold people accountable i mean
prison correctional officers
some of them are really decent people
some of them are
sadists there's all sorts of things in
between
um but you know
it's this is this is kind of a dismay
thing to think about
i just don't see abolition as as
workable and why not spend that effort
on trying to improve things even if you
only improve
one even if you only improve the the
lives
of people in one cell block that is an
achievement
that is something worth doing right
uh just as much as like improving the
life of people in one city block
is improving people's lives right so
all right that's probably enough about
that um no more backer wars
uh do my teaching experiences inform my
philosophical views and vice versa yeah
i would say um you
when you teach stuff and this is part of
what i miss about
being in the classroom due to covid when
you teach stuff and you interact with
people
and you see what they're what they're
getting out of a text and what they're
not
understanding and how you have to
explain it to them and
and you know what they kick back and
they're like yeah listen i think
aristotle's wrong on that
um you really do learn something in the
process
so yeah um
oh cody asked what text would you
recommend to those who suggest america
is comparable to the roman empire
william shirer who is well known for his
rise and fall of the third reich which
is a big thick book he wrote another big
thick book called the
decline and fall of the french third
republic which is
explaining why the french third republic
fell to the nazis
so so quickly it wasn't that they they
were cowards or
you know didn't fight or anything like
that um it was
the rot from within in in the uh the
political system
um savage dragon what how do you think
humanity
is adapting to the current fourth
industrial revolution big data
in regards to the influx of information
the individual has to filter and
synthesize to evaluate truth now
um well if you're asking like how do i
think
humans are adapting in terms of like
doing good or bad i'd say we do we're
mostly doing pretty bad aren't we
right um
are they adapting um i mean i think a
lot of people have like
just decided
and this goes to the ideological thing
and the the echo chambers
a lot of people have just said well i'm
only going to get my sources from over
here
because i want things to be you know
simpler straightforward i want a
narrative that i can
i can trust and then you know they get
their their other news
from the other sources filtered through
those you know so like
you watch um so you know we can take fox
and msnbc right both have ideological
bents
and you'll get your take on people from
the other side
from from them and it'll it'll be really
filtered
um
so i don't know are are we really
adapting um
it's it's tough we do have a vast flood
of information i suppose some people
probably just specialize and they're
like i
i only care about this thing over here
and that's that's a form of you know
atomizing as we call it um we're
thinking about like social
theory where each person just becomes
their own little
moan ad in respects i mean
the idea of are people
more here's here's a question i'll throw
out there are are the average
person more of a consumer than they were
in the past or is the capacity to like
say things on social media does that
mean that you're
you're still mostly a consumer but
you're you're also
getting to be a producer in in some
respects
um i don't know that's that's a good
good question
um
azial your take on which perspective in
international relations theory is the
best explanatory power
i don't know i'm not an international
relations guy
um a friend of mine is a
benedictine monk who studies
studied medieval philosophies on his
whole life and made a lot of
contributions to father john fortin
but his real love was international
relations and he would tell me about
that
quite a bit but that's that's not really
an uh a field of mine
um all right fedo remains i know this
isn't about hobbs but i'd like to know
your thoughts on the end of mcintyre's
after virtue how he claims you can be
entering into
the new dark ages which are already upon
us i'd say
you know that i'd say that's that's uh
still correct
i think that mcintyre is significantly
right about
um the breakdown of moral concepts and
language
i think that um he's also quite correct
about there isn't going to be a savior
coming from the right or the left
to fix things and i think he's also
right to focus on the need to
identify the goods that are that are
there for us
don't trust institutions but realize
that we still have to work within
institutions
and try to build whatever communities we
can
to continue things on without without
necessarily
buying into the idea that because we've
created this community everything's
going to be
you know great going forward and and we
should also be very distrustful of
ideological
bases for those communities
you know don't we don't want a whole
bunch of new grand inquisitors i guess
you could say
um
dylan says i saw in one of your videos
you had a discussion about nietzsche and
what might be considered a modern day
uber manchester thinking today's
athletes might meet these
those requirements no not at all it's
not just about physical prowess
and being an athlete in one respect
doesn't mean that you're necessarily
going to be useful for anything in any
other respect i mean
a lot of athletes are very um
hyper-specialized
being an uber men should be you know way
more than just being a great physical
specimen you'd have to be
brilliant and in many respects kind of
ruthless
and so i'm not sure
athletes exemplify that
all right i think we may be at the end
of our we've
sort of worn out this this topic i don't
see any any new
questions and uh i have a lot of work
unfortunately that i've
put off over the weekend i have to do
now
uh to pay the piper so to speak
in terms of course development and all
that i have a new class actually
starting today
uh intro to philosophy class with
milwaukee area technical college and
it's a compressed eight-week class
and i'll tell you this a lot of students
don't
realize that eight week classes are
going to be you know about twice as as
much
stuff each week as a 15 to 16 week class
and so they start themselves off behind
and then they they get behind it's
really hard to catch up
you know um but yeah so think people are
saying thanks for the presentation yeah
i'm glad
you know these these bits and pieces of
political theory from the past can often
be interesting i think i will
do something down the line on
dostoevsky's grand inquisitor chapter
because it's often
misunderstood uh it's much more complex
than
what a lot of people present it as but
next uh next uh not next year next
month i'm actually going to focus on
aristotle's discussion
of of slavery
in politics book one and on all the
interconnected issues with that rosty
says he's got a question
regarding science fiction what's the
connection between slipstream genre and
post-modernism
i don't even know what slipstream genre
is and uh
i i doubt there's any connection to
postmodernism as
you know one big movement thing it's
it's probably connected to some
post-modern
idea or author or something like that
but i don't know what slipstream
genre is so all right i'm going to say
uh good night to some of you because
some of you started off by saying good
evening
so you're probably in europe or africa
uh or or maybe even further uh uh
around the world um some of you may be
uh
maybe the middle of the night for you
some of you this may be
uh early afternoon or if you're you know
further west
um still the morning so i'm gonna say
bye and i'll see you next time